cette invité aujourd'hui c'est
l'ethnologue et anthropologue Véronique
naom grappe bonjour merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci
pour vous vous êtes spécialiste des
crimes de guerre notamment et vous êtes
l'un des 79 contributeurs à cet ouvrage
qui est magistral il est sorti le mois
dernier s'appelle Siri le pays brûlé le
Livre noir des Assad
1970 2021 c'est plus qu'un livre c'est
en gros une œuvre encyclopédique pour
comprendre la Syrie la dictature 50 ans
de de règne d'apaise à la salle et de
son fils Bachar
il fait oeuvre de mémoire d'histoire et
d'avertissement les éditions du Seuil et
c'est pas faux c'est très documenté ça
dénonce les crimes commis par le régime
syrien pendant près de 50 ans et tout
d'abord alors là-dedans il y a beaucoup
de spécialistes du Moyen-Orient de
spécialistes de la Syrie de journalistes
de politologue de géopolitologue d'abord
quelle est l'apport de la vision du
nethnologue sur la Syrie dans cet
ouvrage si je voudrais juste
un peu avant dire un peu l'histoire de
ce livre tel que je m'en souviens avec
émotion je dois dire on était à une
manifestation lors de la chute d'Alep
donc nous sommes en décembre 2016 avec
Catherine cocuo je vais lui brèche
quelques amis et on était dévastés de
ces manifestations vous savez on n'est
pas sinon nombreux ou les causes sont
majeures
la cositivement et on est un petit
groupe mineur et on rentre on dit
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour faire un
comité Syrie comme il y avait eu grâce à
la et on remercie la revue Esprit des
bergers ces comités parfois qui tentent
de travailler sur des situations dont le
tragique nous dépasse et c'est dans le
cadre de ce comité que petit à petit
grâce avec l'aide d'Olivier Mongin de
tous les gens qui sont là et le travail
magistral de jacques-lubrèche de
Catherine coccio de plein d'autres aussi
que je m'excuse de ne pas nommer je veux
pas 70 ans
qui ont traduit qui ont travaillé et
pendant six ans tout ce travail et c'est
un voilà on était désespéré mais c'est
quand même quelque chose à ajouter dire
deux choses la manière de faire c'est
une couture
très réfléchie c'est-à-dire par exemple
quelle idée géniale d'avoir mis en
prologue ce texte d'un grand écrivain
syrien qui est l'auteur donc du roman la
coquille et donc qui s'appelle Mustapha
Khalifé et qui en 2012 alors que la
victoire était sur le terrain acquise au
mouvement disons au début des lents
démocratiques contre ce pouvoir que l'on
va définir bientôt
et il a eu un espèce de il a fait une
anticipation un texte on est en 2012 et
si Bachar el-Assad gagné il a fait un
texte et ce texte et dans le prologue de
ce livre il fallait le trouver et après
en 2018 on lui a demandé un autre texte
et donc ces deux textes sont là et c'est
pour vous dire un peu le travail je
dirais de réflexion qu'est-ce qu'on
propose à l'oeil du lecteur on lui
propose pas seulement des faits on lui
propose pas seulement une histoire
difficile sur laquelle il faudrait
travailler mais on lui propose des clés
non seulement les faits non seulement
les témoignages mais des clés de
compréhension et des mises en contexte
autre exemple et il se grand massacre un
mât donc là on est en février 82 1982
donc le clan des Hassad avait possédé ce
pays dès les années 70 c'est la première
grande répression menée par Raphaël ça
va être l'objet d'une amnésie obligée de
d'un mensonge politique d'effacement
total et non seulement dans le livre il
y a les faits il y a des témoignages
mais il y a 10 ans après un travail
d'une historienne
anthropologue qui qui reprend qui fait
naître le souvenir le souvenir va
revenir va revenir dans la mémoire de
des gens qui sont qui ont survécu qui
ont été témoin et voyez ce comment un
même fait va être éclairé de façon
différente ça c'est très intéressant et
d'autres parce que je voulais dire aussi
c'est qu'il y a un enjeu difficile dans
ce livre donc une couverture un peu de
temps historique un peu longue quand
même premièrement le temps hélas
ce dilate et on ne voit pas la fin bon
et deuxièmement le fait qu'il y a trois
grands champs je dirais de destructivité
du pouvoir si rien actuel il y a cette
problématique des massacres aléatoire
quand il y a des rébellions depuis le
père Assad le fils aussi d'ailleurs
dire etc qu'il faut documenter qui font
tourner et qui sont très nombreux et
dans des lieux très différents et là
j'ai pas le temps là je renvoie vraiment
au livre il y a deuxième grand champ le
système pénitentiel de ce régime ou là
il a inventé quelque chose c'est pas un
système pénitentiel c'est un des prisons
plus ou moins clandestine certaines
complètement d'extermination de la
population d'ailleurs de nombreux
massacres à des Rayas Palmyre émaillés
dans le temps au lieu dans les prisons
c'est pas des lieux d'incarcération
normaux ce sont des lieux
d'extermination des populations surtout
les prisonniers politiques hommes femmes
enfants avec des tortures dont on a
épargné ici les images parce que les
images sont très nombreuses très
documentées très sérieuses et notamment
raison de fuite auprès du régime et le
dossier César mais je vais pas y venir
je laisse les lecteurs etc et le
troisième grand champ de criminalité
politique ce qu'on la guerre va se
déclencher avec l'aide donc des Iraniens
et des avions
là il va y avoir des des situations
d'enfer pour les populations à la fois
de siège comme dans la le quartier de
yarmoux qui va être affamé et qui des
gens vont mourir de faim ils vont être
bombardés affamés avec des mots
absolument insensés et enfin bien sûr la
chute d'Alep placer une tragédie absolue
Alep qui était une ville les plus belles
il y a un écrivain qui a parlé des
balcons d'Alep il se souvient des
balcons d'Alep où il y a la foi des
petits oliviers qui poussent des
aubergines les dames qui font des clins
d'oeil il a une description magnifique
mais c'est fini les bagues qu'on allait
parce que danser les guerres de
destruction il y a une dimension
d'urbitides le quartier historique Damas
avait été rasé c'est pas seulement les
massacres si les bulldozers c'est les
bombes c'est et donc si vous voulez la
dimension de la guerre est présente
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au jusqu'à la façon
dont on traite dans les camps de
réfugiés les réfugiés syriens syriens
qui arrivent aux frontières de la
Turquie et où les pouvoirs empêchent
l'humanitaires d'arriver de façon
correcte si vous voulez alors qu'il y a
des inondations et en ce moment en Syrie
il y a le choléra il y a toutes les
alertes donc si vous voulez vous aviez
ces trois grands champs qu'il fallait
quand même
établir et en même temps la décision
très juste du du groupe été de ne pas
donner toutes ces photos très nombreuses
et d'ailleurs c'est une réflexion ici
dans le livre sur le Seguer ou
maintenant nous avons les photos et des
photos absolument crédibles puisqu'elles
viennent du régime même qui filme les
horreurs qu'ils font et donc vous voyez
moi je suis d'une génération j'ai passé
mon temps à penser que si on avait connu
les camps de concentration lors de la
guerre du milieu du 20e siècle mais on
peut plus dire la dernière guerre et
bien si on savait on aurait fait quelque
chose mais là on sait on a les photos
alors aurait-on eu les photos de
l'entrée du du four du camp d'Auschwitz
qu'on aurait trouvé qu'on aurait un bon
vous voyez ça nous met dans des abîmes
de réflexion et
pense que c'est le cas pour l'Ukraine
aussi on en reparlera un peu plus tard
de
rester très décentes il
y a des il y a des textes de réflexion
et jamais de façon comment dire
on épargne rien au lecteur parce que
c'est le réel mais on veut absolument le
traité avec tact le lecteur est traité
avec tact et vous vous intéressez à la
question de l'impunité votre chapitre à
vous et vous dites que l'impunité c'est
cette évidence partagée entre le
criminel sa victime le cercle des
témoins tout autour que nul
n'empêchement nul punition devant
intervenir non seulement pendant
l'action criminelle elle-même mais pas
non plus dans sa suite plausible en
Syrie c'est des décennies d'état
d'urgence l'espoir d'une garantie de
stabilité qui ont maintenu cette chape
de plomb c'est aussi simple que ça
l'impunité il y a une dimension
juridique que tout le monde connaît sur
laquelle il y a des travaux et moi ma
dimension c'était qu'est-ce que ça
signifie
dans le faire société dans les échanges
entre les voisins
le cadre c'est un cadre le fait que les
bourreaux bah ceux qui portent
l'uniforme c'est qu'on peut pas on peut
pas faire comme avec comme en France un
fait divers à Trans on verra la police
dont on espère qu'elle va trouver les
coupables dont on espère qu'ils seront
jugés dans des bonnes conditions
correctes c'est impossible dans
l'impunité dans un état dictatorial la
majorité des crimes sont faits par des
gens qui ont l'uniforme et qui sont ceux
qui devraient vous protéger ceux qui
vous torturent et qui vous assassine et
donc c'est le cadre même du pouvoir qui
assure cette espèce de de confort si
vous voulez des acteurs ils savent que
nul rétention ne viendra renvoyer
quelque chose des crimes qui sont en
train d'accomplir alors il y a plusieurs
cercles de l'impunité c'est ça que je
voulais il y a un cercle mettons en
situation en temps réel peut-on vous
avez un bourreau dans les prisons de
cette Naïa dans les dans les prisons
cyrielles et là avec le temps il va le
bourreau ici c'est son boulot lui dit
même bravo plus les cruel plus il prouve
plus il y aura de l'avancement il prouve
qu'il est un bon sujet loyal plus les
cruels donc la cruauté devient une
valeur politique et puis qu'est-ce qu'on
a avec la durée à un moment il téléphone
à sa femme pour avoir des infos sur le
repas du soir tout en écorchant vif son
prisonnier il s'arrête un peu à l'eau
chéri etc c'est-à-dire que l'impunité
fabrique autour du corps du bourreau en
situation un tel confort qui finit par
s'ennuyer et on a beaucoup de textes ici
et j'en cite un pour l'autre guerre pour
la guerre de 14 mais je l'ai trouvé par
un peu par hasard ou le bureau le
bourreau assuré par la guillemets
jouissance de l'impunité qui est un
terme intéressant parce que c'est pas
une jouissance au sens sexuel mais c'est
une jouissance au sens le beau paysage
la tranquillité il joue de l'impunité et
donc il s'ennuie et donc il cherche
encore plus
encore plus donc avec l'impunité va la
surenchère et ça c'est au niveau de du
premier comment dire du second couteau
qui fait les crimes c'est pas lui qui
les commande mais il est quand même au
premier rang du de la cruauté en geste
surtout si vous qui violent qu'il est
etc et par contre arrive la deuxième le
deuxième cercle de l'impunité qui vient
du politique et là vous avez le tyran
qui doit assurer son impunité puisqu'en
général ce type d'origine fonctionne sur
trois volets prédation pour un clan donc
prédation économique vol mafia etc à
tous les niveaux le cruauté l'usage de
la cruauté pour la terreur pour la
domination donc ce que ce rappel la fin
de l'État c'est-à-dire qu'il y a plus de
tiers il y a plus de contre-pouvoir etc
et 3 le mensonge politique parce que
pour assurer l'impunité il faut une
version des faits qui puisse la couvrir
complètement et donc le travail même
d'un Poutine actuellement ou d'un Bachar
el-Assad ils ont des services ils
travaillent à la version des faits qui
fait glisser et qui empêche de penser et
dont on est obligé à l'intérieur de
l'adopter comme vérité c'est un calque
qu'on peut appliquer à plusieurs
situations par exemple les le non
respect des droits de l'homme en ce
moment dans les régions occupées en
Ukraine le viol utilisé comme arme de
masse d'ailleurs l'aide de Poutine qui a
sauvé Bachar al-Assad alors qu'il était
perdu avec les il y avait ce sublime
mouvement des printemps arabes un des
plus beaux historiques du début du 21e
siècle et donc vous avez ce ces deux
pouvoirs qui s'entre ressemblent qui se
sont reconnus qui ont flairé là en face
de l'autre ils ont reniflé l'odeur des
larmes du sang suintant dans le corps de
l'autre et son frère et ils se sont les
mêmes ils peuvent aussi s'entre
poignardées dans le dos s'ils étaient
tous les deux voilà en situation de
concurrence donc si vous voulez le fait
que
Poutine et participer de façon avec une
cruauté dans les bombardements ciblant
expressément une première fois le lieu
de soins ou déjà des gens victimes
enfants population civile de bombe sont
soignés et après arrivent à l'horizon un
petit avion d'un point noir dans le ciel
c'est un avion russe qui vient bombarder
ce centre de soins parce que les Russes
avaient toutes les adresses des centres
de soins en Syrie des disons à plombés
des démocrates je les dénon des
résistants contre Bachar et ils
utilisaient pour les bombardés et donc
si vous voulez c'était c'était une
tragédie absolue c'était de Poutine à
Bachar el-Assad et ses deux pouvoirs qui
évidemment ont besoin du mensonge pour
couvrir le crime évidemment merci
beaucoup Veronique je suis désolé on est
pressé par le temps on aurait pu dire
que c'est bombardements russes il se
poursuivent d'ailleurs en Syrie ils ont
même été très intense la semaine
dernière on aurait pu parler aussi de
votre tribune que vous signez dans
Libération le mois dernier avec de
nombreux universitaires tribunes qui
appellent l'État français à agir face à
la répression en Iran je renvoie la
libération et puis donc aussi à ce livre
qui est magistral s'appelle le Cyril le
pays brûlé c'est une véritable
encyclopédie de la Syrie de ses 50
dernières années extrêmement documentées
qui servira peut-être et c'est bien ce
qui s'est passé un jour qui rend
possible ce qui se passe en Ukraine
actuellement c'est bien l'impunité au
crime syrien qui rend possible
l'actualité et les crimes du pouvoir du
Kremlin merci beaucoup
Ukraine merci à vous merci